une pandémie qui a bouleversé nos
contacts humains le sociologue français
michel fize est en plateau avec nous
pour en discuter car l'épidémie risque
de perturber nos rapports humains et
notamment dans ce contexte de fait notre
société a tendance à multiplier les
situations sans contact humain n'est ce
pas quelque chose qui à terme pourrait
devenir dangereux est ce que
pensait et que penser de noël avec des
contacts limités alors je crois que
c'est une tendance lourde de nos
sociétés d'un autre en particulier un
que que de voir se réduire et même
disparaître les contacts humains nous
connaissons tous les supermarchés sans
caissière
les stations-service en pompiste il ya
déjà très longtemps les agence bancaire
ou postal sans agent et puis on a même
inventé les cartes bancaires sans
contact
alors ce qui est assez extraordinaire
c'est que le mot contacts etc en quelque
sorte devenu tabou 1 kg at-il de pire
aujourd'hui en période de pandémie
qu'être un cas contacts alors qu'en fin
de compte contact c'est le propre des
sociétés 1 ça ça veut dire le lien entre
entre les gens alors le virus lui il a
une autre stratégie 1 il a d'ailleurs
ses porte parole politique maintenant et
on nous répète à longueur de temps ne
vous y trompez pas ne vous réunissez pas
ne vous touchez pas ne vous embrasser
pas ne vous en lasser pas ne fait pas la
fête quand je me dis mais peut-être
qu'un jour on va dire mais ne prenez
plus vos enfants sur les genoux ne le
fait plus de câlins fait leur porter un
masque ou laver les mains en permanence
voilà donc tout ceci nous nous éloigne
évidemment de ce qu'est une société qui
est encore une fois le rapprochement
entre les gens selon vous michel fize
lakovic 19 va-t-elle finir à
déshumaniser en quelque sorte nos
sociétés alors ça commençait par ce
qu'on appelle la dématérialisation
vous savez aujourd'hui on a plus de
papier entre les mains un tout se passe
sur des sites internet à coups de
formulaires de robots qui vous remplace
il ya plus de contacts téléphoniques un
essayer d'avoir
un agent quelconque d'une administration
au bout du téléphone bon donc il ya déjà
de l'humain de l'humain qui a disparu
alors aujourd'hui évidemment on a on a
encore une fois une surenchère avec
encore une fois des mots qu'on pensait
avoir disparu le mot barrière barrière
c'est la fermeture on vous dit gestes
barrières donc c'est du positif voilà
mêmes on vous dit mais finalement il
faut rétablir les frontières dans les
aéroports sur les routes 1 ne plus
laisser passer 1 donc on est à l'
inverse de ce qui est une société qui
est la libre circulation qui est la
disparition des des frontières je crois
qu'il faut dire que au nom de la
sécurité sanitaire tout n'est pas permis
et que le nouveau monde dont on rêve
dont on a pu rêver haut débit thd début
de la pandémie bas ce sera tout sauf un
monde sans contact une société bien
pensé c'est une société avec des
contacts michel fize comment réagir face
à cette situation qui est inédite dans
l'histoire mais d'abord on nous persuade
ans nous ne sommes pas condamnés à vivre
dans des sociétés sans contact qu'il
faut peut-être lutter contre l' des
matrices dématérialisation dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et lutter contre
contre finalement cette dénomination
encore une fois
vivre sans contact ce n'est pas vivre ce
n'est pas bien vivre c'est survivre donc
la pandémie nous transformant des sortes
de deux survivants or nous avons besoin
d'échanger nous avons besoin de mille
touché le tactile c'est aussi c'est
aussi important pour nous sentir utile
pour nous sentir heureux voilà donc je
pense qu'on ne doit pas accepter d'une
situation qui fait de nous des sortes de
loups solitaires 1 qui doivent se garder
un on aurait presque un nouveau et
nouvel adage méfiez-vous les uns des
autres ouais c'est quand même loin de la
convivialité de la sociabilité qui
encore une fois sont les ressorts
profonds de nos sociétés merci beaucoup
michel pis pour votre analyse en vous
nous dites donc il faut continuer à
consolider entre viendront dire pour
vous souhaiter un joyeux noël et ben
voyons ceux qui nous écoutent merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci